-Our next guest is a talente
actor you know from shows
like "Lost," "Deadwood,"
and "Sons of Anarchy,"
and films such as
"Gone Baby Gone" and "Argo."
He stars in "Bosch,"
which premieres its final season
June 25th on Amazon Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-How long have you known?
-What?
-About Pena and the feds.
-I don't know what
you're talking about.
-I got five innocent victims
and you're asking me to stan
down on the ring leader?
-It's not an ask.
It's a direct order.
Sometimes we have to
make compromises
for the greater good.
-Bull[bleep]
This man lost his only child
and you of all people should b
able to relate to that.
-Mother[bleep], get out.
-Welcome to the show
Titus Welliver.
Nice to see you, my friend
-That was an introduction.
-[ Laughs ]
We like to introduce peopl
by another actor telling the
to get the [bleep] out.
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't tell you how man
times Reddick and I did that
because I couldn't keep
a straight face.
That's acting right there.
I'll tell you.
-Yeah. Lance Reddick.
I mean, one of the great joy
of the show "Bosch"
is how frustrated
he is with you constantly.
Through seven seasons,
he's never gotten used to
Bosch's behavior.
-No, no, not at all.
And, you know, the thing about
it is that people say,
"Oh, Lance Reddick --
he's really intense."
And I go, "He's a complete
Boo Boo the Fool."
We joke all the time.
We call each other
Boo Boo the fool
because all we do is talk abou
comic books, "Star Trek."
He's silly.
He's a silly, silly guy.
But, you know, when they cal
"action," he goes into lockdown.
-Yes, certainly in the roles
I know him for,
very little silliness.
I first became familiar with you
on "Lost," and I think
because of that,
it never occurred to me
that you were
a fellow New Englander.
You grew up in Maine.
Is that right?
-I spent my summers there, and I
went to boarding school there.
So I had -- I spent a lot of
time in Maine and in Boston,
and in -- you know, your neck of
the woods, not Franconia,
but a lot of time there.
So I consider myself
a New Englander 100%.
-Well, I think the highest
praise you can get as an actor
from New England is being cast
in multiple Ben Affleck movies
which has been the case.
You know, that's not a guy
who doesn't have an ear for it
-That's true. That's true.
When I went in and met him
for "Gone Baby Gone,"
and I was doing
the audition thing,
and I said,
"Here, you know what?
I'll do it again,
and I'll dial the accent down.
And he went, "No, no, no, no
no, no, please, keep it there.
And then we would get on set
and I would do, you know, a take
and he'd come over and he woul
say, "I'm losing the accent.
And I would say,
"Ben, if I go any harder,
we're going to need subtitles.
And he said, "I don't care
It's got to be grounded."
And I was relieved because
with the exception I think o
"Good Will Hunting"
and prior to that was
"The Friends of Eddie Coyle,
which was, like,
the quintessential Boston film
because everything else wa
a bad "Pepperidge Farm
Remembers" commercial,
which was so offensive,
I'm sure to you.
When I hear that, I go,
"Better to not do it."
-You also went to NYU with
a fellow from my hometown.
He was there first, I should
establish, but Adam Sandler.
And you guys were in a comed
writing class together.
Did you have an early sens
of his talent in that field?
-You know, he's just one o
those guys that's always funny
And so we ended up
in this class together,
and I took it
just because it seemed lik
an interesting class,
and I knew Adam.
But we were immediately, after
the first class, were separate
and were not allowed
to sit together anymore.
I mean, you know, we're at NYU
It's not like we were
in third grade.
[ Laughter ]
I would just look at him,
and he would say things like
"I really can't wait
to get a cup of coffee
and a bag of Cheetos."
[ Laughter ]
And I would lose it
in the middle of the class
You know, they would go, "Adam
Titus, guys, come on, please."
And so it became, you know, we
thoroughly enjoyed torturing
this poor assistant professor.
She deeply disliked us,
and I don't know why
other than maybe she just ha
a thing about New Englanders
But I was really kind of lucky
in that way,
is that I got to see Adam, you
know, so early in his career
I would go and see him in little
comedy clubs all over Manhattan.
And, you know, he's an original.
The stuff he was doing then wa
not -- You didn't say,
"Well, that reminds me of X.
It was -- You know,
Sandler is his own guy.
And you know, his success
has been, you know,
a really nice thing to observe
because he's a really good
human being.
-He's one of
the all-time greats.
I said to him that I don't think
he has a New Hampshire accen
as much as every kid I grew up
with in New Hampshire
had an Adam Sandler accent
because once he became famous,
like, every kid I went to
high school with was like,
[as Sandler] "Oh, here we go."
[ Normal voice ] I was like,
that's not a regional dialect.
You're just doing Adam Sandler
-Nobody in New Hampshire
is talking like this.
[ Laughter ]
And the ice cream --
"Eat your goddamn ice cream.
I'll kill ya."
[ Laughter ]
-I am always fascinated by early
roles that actors have.
And you were sort of known for
playing, you know,
in sort of grittier fare,
but you had a part in "90210."
What was your part,
and what was your father's
reaction when he saw it?
-I played this guy who was thi
alcoholic boyfriend to this girl
who was trying to make
a sober go of it.
And Luke Perry --
God rest his soul --
was her sponsor and friend
And my character was kind of
jealous and we got into a thing,
and Luke Perry, who was
considerably smaller than I was,
took me out with one punch
You know, he was laughing.
I mean, we had a great time.
And he was a warm and welcomin
and lovely guy.
But I didn't even tell my father
that I was on this thing.
And I got a call from him
the next day, and he --
calling from his house in Maine,
and he said, "Yeah, that thing
you were on last night,
what is it?
Los Angeles 9-51-62."
I said, "Oh, yeah, '90210.'"
And he went, "Yeah, well,
whatever it's called.
Don't ever do that again."
And I said, "What? Why?"
And he went,
"Yeah, it's bad for your soul.
[ Laughter ]
And I went, "Well, Dad,
I've got to pay my bills."
And he said, "Son,
if you need money that badly
I'll send you some."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's
the kind of support
every actor should be
lucky to have.
That's a very kind thing
for a father to do for his son
-Yeah, the subtext was,
"Hold out for Scorsese."
And I was like, "Oh, okay.
Right now I'm
in Jason Priestley Land,
but I hope to get there
someday."
-Hey, congratulations so muc
on seven seasons.
Thanks so much for making time
with us today.
It was great talking to you.
-Thank you.
Great talking to you.
It was a pleasure.
-The seventh and final seaso
of "Bosch"
premieres June 25th
on Amazon Prime Video.